-Thank you so much.
Welcome back to the show.
-Thanks for having me back.
-Whenever.
I got to say congratulations
to you.
Since last I saw you,
you have a baby.
-I know.
-A beautiful baby.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Does he love it
when Mom sings to him?
Do you sing lullabies?
-Oh.
No.
[ Laughter ]
No, he hates it.
-Baby doesn't like it at all?
-No, he's my biggest critic.
[ Laughter ]
-He's like, "You gotta work on
that one."
-No, it's funny. My mom, she
can't carry a tune in a bucket.
[ Laughter ]
It's really bad,
and when she sings,
his eyes light up like she's
the stars and the moon.
-He loves it.
[ Audience aws ]
-But when I sing,
he's not a fan.
[ Laughter ]
-Is that, really?
-Not a fan. I get the...
-Oh, no. Yeah, don't cry.
Oh, no. I know that face.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, you're -- Oh.
-I'm like, "Alright. Okay."
Most kids would be really happy.
[ Laughter ]
-Are you loving being on tour?
This is the Love and Power Tour.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love the poster.
-Thank you.
Yeah, it's been really
incredible.
It's been amazing.
I miss touring so much.
And, you know, there was a
minute there where I didn't know
if I was going to be able to do
it for a while.
-Yeah.
-And being back on the road
and seeing people in the crowd
coming alive to the lyrics --
-That's part of you.
-Yeah, it's incredible.
-Your new single is "So Good,"
by the way.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Yeah.
-"So Good."
-The name is really, really
funny because when we're having
conversations about it,
you know, I'll play it for
somebody and they'll be like,
"Oh, it's so good."
[ Laughter ]
-You're like, "No, literally,
it's 'So Good.'"
-That's exactly what it is.
-Exactly, that's the name
of the song.
But finally, the song is out.
-Yeah.
-Does it feel good that the song
is out?
-Yeah, it feels amazing.
I think as an artist,
you just want to be able
to release things. You know?
Like, music is such a cool
industry because you have
the luxury to put stuff out
as soon as it comes to you,
as soon as it's a thought
and a feeling
and it's current to the moment.
So I was really, really keen to
just kind of get this out now
while I was just feeling it.
-It's a beautiful love song.
-Yeah, it is. I wrote it about
my partner love.
Yeah, I did.
And he and I met in
a really cool way.
-How?
-I met him in 2017
and he was hired to write
a movie about me.
-Ooh. Oh, that's right.
He's a director and a writer.
-Uh-huh. So he was hired to
write a movie about me,
kind of like "8 Mile."
Less spaghetti.
You know?
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, yeah.
-Yeah.
But I was going to wear
the cool hoodie, though.
-Yeah, you have to.
-So he kind of followed me
around on tour.
And he was interviewing me.
And after a couple of years of
getting to know me,
one day I kind of sat down
and I was like,
"Hey, you know everything
about me.
I don't know anything about you.
I'm going to start interviewing
you back."
And we found out that we had
so much in common.
-You fell in love.
-After being friends for a long
time, we fell in love. Yeah.
-That's the best way to do it.
-I know.
-Come on, congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-That's the best way to do it.
To be friends, go like, "Hey, I
just want to hang out with you."
-Yeah.
-What happened to the biopic?
-Okay, well, there's a conflict
of interest now
because he's a --
he's a main character.
[ Laughter ]
But he got to direct
the music video instead,
which was really cool.
So it's kind of like a mini
taste of what could be.
-I was thinking about
who could play you.
-Oh, God.
I know the answer.
-Is it who I think it -- Ready?
Here's who I think
should play you.
Well, this is you.
But this is you as
Millie Bobby Brown.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, I was going to say you.
-Do you think I should play you?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-What? No.
-No?
-Millie Bobby Brown
should play you. Yeah.
-I mean, yeah, Millie
would be great.
But I don't really think I'm
famous enough to cast Millie.
You'll do it though, right?
-Of course.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No, Millie would be so great.
Millie -- I mean, it's kind of
uncanny how much we look alike.
It's like, "Oh, no. We actually
just look like sisters."
-Yeah, you really do.
-Yeah.
-I was just talking about you
because the great Adam Sandler
was on our show last week.
-Aw!
-And he loves you and he said
that -- he told me that you
performed at his daughter's
bat mitzvah.
-I did. I did. It was awesome.
[ Audience aws ]
First of all, it was
the craziest bat mitzvah
I've ever seen in my life.
-Oh, yeah.
-As you would expect
from Adam Sandler.
It was like -- I mean, it was
like Coachella.
-Really?
[ Laughter ]
-I couldn't believe it.
And also, I was like,
"Wow, you guys booked me?"
I was really honored.
But his daughters are great.
And he's so amazing.
-Oh, so cute.
-It was a really cool
full-circle moment too because
when I was a kid, his movies
used to play in my house
all the time, right?
-Yeah.
-And my dad is a huge golfer
and loved "Happy Gilmore."
He used to watch it
all the time.
And so my first sentence that
I ever spoke in my life
was "Go home, ball."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-Is that right?
-Yeah, so I would run around
like a baby.
Like, crawling around on
the floor.
-"Go to your home."
-"Go to your home, ball."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's the best.
-Yeah.
-That's your first sentence?
-I want to talk about
your new makeup line.
-Oh, yeah, about-face.
It's, like, the best --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is something --
-The best idea I ever had.
-Speaking of something
that you can't just do
and have it come out
the same week,
this takes years of work
and research and stuff.
So much work goes into it.
-It is. Yeah.
Also, like, I'm a little --
I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-Say it.
-Neurotic.
-Yeah.
Like, controlling?
-Nnnn, in a good way.
I want everything to be perfect
all of the time, you know?
-Wow.
-So, I really spent a lot
of time just, like, meticulously
working on the formulas.
-Like, how nerdy do you get
when it comes to it?
-Ooh, nerdy.
-Really?
-Yeah. "This has too much
hyaluronic acid.
We need to reduce the amount
because the formula's
too creamy." Yeah.
-Are you wearing
a lab coat and goggles?
-I literally am acting like
I'm trying to, like, cure
a disease in my basement.
-And you're making makeup just
to make everyone feel better?
-Yeah. It's tough, though,
because I'm a musician,
so I'm on stage.
So my products need to be
so long wear, so good,
so high performance
because if I get on stage
and my lipstick starts smearing
all over the place,
people are like,
"I'm not buying that."
-Exactly. Yeah, of course.
-You know?
-It's got to work.
-Yeah.
-Congrats on about-face.
Congrats on the tour.
-Thank you.
-Congrats on the new music.
And, of course,
congrats on baby.
That's the greatest.
-Aw, thank you so much.
-Halsey, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We love you.
Halsey and I are playing
"The Best Friends Challenge"
when we come back.
Stick around.